first up it's breakfast my spiced baked
porridge
absolutely love it why
I grew up with it there's something very
Scottish about porridge it's that kind
of sort of great start to the day my
father used to say porridge needs salt
and salt only it separates the men from
the boys didn't really like it it was
insisted salt puts hairs on it I used to
sneak a couple of sugar lumps from cafes
and put them in my porridge without him
watching these days my porridge has much
more flavor than just salt it's packed
with fruit nuts and spices add vanilla
seeds to porridge oats or oatmeal really
important just to rub the vanilla
through
the oatmeal makes it nice and fragrant
now a little teaspoon
of cinnamon makes it spicier and then
nutmeg
[Music]
already
that smells incredible I quite like
making this up week at a time and
Jack absolutely loves it now whole
almonds
now if you don't like that kind of
crunch running through the porridge you
can chop these up or blend them to a
powder but I quite like the sort of
texture hazelnuts incredibly good really
nice crunch keep your vanilla pot in
there as well that just gives it even
more lift and of course once it's baked
just pull it out instead of sugar I'm
adding sweetness with fruit fresh pears
and raisins
cranberries are great as well chopped
apricots as well dried apricots in there
dried mango I love dried fruit next pour
in a pint of milk and mix
this can be done the night before left
in the fridge and then a couple of
minutes before you go to bake it add
your cream
into your dish
it looks quite liquid
but by the time it bakes has this really
nice rich crust on top and then
just a nice little nutmeg
on top now bake at 180 for 30 to 35
minutes
then take the porridge out sprinkle on
Demerara sugar and Grill to create a
sweet Golden Crust
and sort of glaze on top
beautiful
literally for three to four minutes
look at that
that makes me feel proud to be Scottish
because it's perfect for a big Comfort
family breakfast it's Rich it's
Sumptuous and it's just a humble oatmeal
phenomenal especially in the winter my
spiced baked porridge with all those
nuts and fruit is a bowl full of love to
start the day
easy homemade spicy baked beans with
deliciously light potato cakes the first
big thing that I remember as a kid was
bacon and beans so this is like a little
rendition
except we're using the most amazing
pancetta Ernie come on
disappear don't chase the mice now panel
get nice and hot I'm gonna turn these
beans into
glamorous beans pancetta into the pan
lightly season that it's cured so it
doesn't need that much seasoning
now start frying off that pancetta
it's amazing how the individual Taste of
baked beans they're somewhat Bland so I
always like to make them a little bit
more spicy
so a nice finely chopped chili with
the seeds chili in
now a bit of garlic
crushed phenomenal
[Music]
get that bacon really nice and crispy
fry off the chili and the garlic
and then onions my top tip for dicing
finely sliced downwards
slice across
then cut down to Simply dice
bacon onion chili garlic for that flavor
all contained in that little Pan Once
you sweat the onion off
a little bit of sugar in there
the brown sugar will start to caramelize
darken and then Rich as well at the same
time a couple of tablespoons cider
vinegar deglaze the pan it's got that
really nice powerful kick to it now
spice that up
with one of my favorite Seasons
Worcester sauce
bring that to the boil
and add your
SATA puree tomatoes
simmer the sauce to reduce then add in
the classic baked bean harico beans
you can buy harika beans dried or canned
They are packed with protein and have a
lovely soft texture turn down the heat
and let the beans absorb
all that beautiful spicy tomato sauce
and just let that simmer now now for my
potato cakes they're a fantastic way to
use leftover boiled potatoes and are so
easy to make
I'm making a simple potato dough by
adding flour and butter to the mash
that gives it that nice sort of cakey
texture take a nice
spoon a potato lightly flour your board
we're going to fry these crisp
on the outside and just nice and fluffy
in the center now
get your pan nice and hot
we'll start off with olive oil into the
pan
now put the butter around the outside
because it starts heating up the time it
goes into the center
also was sort of nut brown
gently
turn it over
love that nice light crisp they look
beautiful
now take them out
potato cake in the middle
and a nice beautiful
spoon
of beans
growing up with beans on toast As a
treat
still to this day after all those years
has not changed my love or attitude for
beans my Smoky spicy homemade baked
beans with light and creamy potato cakes
comfort and satisfaction on a plate